hello everyone welcome to another
episode of our
wolfram language design
meetings
this is an incremental language
development meeting and we have a
variety of topics today
and our first topic
is minimum aspect ratios for trees so i
think i have to move this into the
prototype build here
and presumably that top one is the right
one
okay so the issue is trees that get too
long and skinny
the other one they're too flat by d by d
oh yeah okay
and that happens also for graphs with um
layered digraph embedding and it will be
lovely to fix that as well i don't know
if charles is here
charles isn't here
but i would like to propose that that
get fixed too
um
so
what are you showing me here i mean
you're showing me
so we proposed a heuristic last time
that we just use whatever aspect ratio
as long as it's at least a fourth and if
it's less than a fourth to set it to a
fourth
okay
and but we also had a heuristic based on
tree splaying angles and things is that
not correct
we didn't quite come up with a heuristic
for that but i'd put a function at the
bottom of this section for getting the
list of angles if we want to
well do we need it i mean
what was the can can you
we need a gallery of bad trees
right does somebody know that gallery
christopher i think this
is the primary one we were looking at
last time
and what does that look at without men
aspect ratio does it just look
completely ridiculous
basically all the nodes look like
they're on a single row
you can evaluate that in a non-prototype
build
and it can have an arbitrarily high
aspect ratio right
yes we don't cap the aspect ratio
because you can have
like
very tall like they play like a path
graph
but even that looks kind of goofy in a
notebook if it goes too long
you get what i'm saying what else do you
want it to do i mean you just wanted to
well i just i want it it's too spindly
it's it's edges right if it has edges
but there's literally nothing it can do
other than just add white padding on
either side right
uh no it can there's a question what the
absolute height actually is
right i mean what absolute height
does tree by default display at
is what i'm saying let me let me do an
example so let's say we say
okay can help me make a tree that is
just a one
one element per thing tree is that a
nest tree can i do that right now
list one range one
yeah
okay
so i claim
oh actually
yeah that's not too stupid okay what i
was concerned about was that yeah you
see here
okay if i were to make this less tall i
would i would be okay let's let's just
do this
okay um
how do i make it less tall can i just
say aspect ratio here
yep
um
okay
that's not helpful
well actually i think that if you have a
graph that's
like a path graph that's totally
vertical like this that the aspect ratio
doesn't
affect anything
doesn't work because i mean because look
this is what i want it to look like
okay something with modest
connections between each thing you see
what i'm saying
i don't need it to look like
something where
it's a giant spider tower so to speak
like this
you get what i'm saying
nothing is nothing is achieved by having
that extra vertical height
right so does that ever actually happen
though like if you run this tree for a
hundred or a thousand
if it doesn't happen there's no problem
right if what doesn't happen
i mean if it doesn't format like that
well it does if i make it wider i mean
it did
forget the i mean i i feel like if you
make it wider that's kind of up to you
you kind of asked for it
well fair enough okay so look here
well you're saying that looks reasonable
because it's as high as it can be so if
i go to 50 for example
or 200 i mean just okay it looks like
it's never going to be taller than that
by default
right make a thousand or something yeah
all right okay fair enough fair enough
fair enough okay my objection is
withdrawn
okay but but what's our gallery of bad
trees i mean we invented that heuristic
with with splaying angles for a reason
and it wasn't just talking about these
kinds of trees
right it's talking about more random
trees we'll do like random tree of a
hundred
okay well let's so if we take it over
here
okay
looking okay i think i mean why aren't
we shrink wrapping
the
i mean in a case like this why aren't we
shrink wrapping closer to the numbers
well here if i say unlabeled tree
in node
is that now that's still tree layout
right
right yeah that's tree layout there's no
it didn't it didn't flip to being graph
layout of any kind right
is that correct in yes
that looks pretty nice to me now if i
move that over here is there anything
going to be different i don't think so
because it's not going to hit the the
aspect ratio limit is it going to render
here
yeah if you evaluate that i i think it
should be
the same aspect ratio since it's at
least a fourth already
yeah
so why did we make up the splaying angle
heuristic what were we doing there
we were looking at
random tree like large random trees
and you thought maybe
there was an issue with some of the
angles being too flat
oh i see within the tree itself but but
but fixable by doing a global aspect
ratio change or fixable within the tree
itself
do you understand my question
no
okay are we expecting that we are
changing the heuristic for or changing
the layout for an individual tree or are
we only suggesting that we might make
decision about the overall aspect ratio
of a tree
just the aspect ratio
i mean so there's a there's a more
more ambitious idea of to try to
actually produce a layout where you have
no
collisions
what do you mean by collisions you mean
collisions i mean okay my next question
is like
data to be taken into account in the
tree layout so that you don't have
overlapping nodes and overlapping labels
oh i see i see i see when the nodes are
not just numbers like this okay my
question is why are we leaving as much
empty space as we are around the numbers
in a case like this
we should shrink wrap
more
for large trees don't waste tree space
by having just empty leaves so to speak
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah so this is this is just using
framed around it there might be an
option to framed to there is there is
let's look at that right now how how we
do that how we have an option how will
we put in the option here
do you understand what i'm asking so is
it a is it a tree vertex shape
or vertex shape function pre-element
shape function
okay
and what we're going to do like
right hand side function
of
inset
first argument framed
oh wait wait wait what are we doing here
then the frame options framed options i
i mean this is look it's wrong it's my
basic point of view when when the thing
when the tree gets this big
let me just um frame margins
here let's just say just for the sake of
doing something let's do fair margins to
zero
okay what else we need in the inside the
argument should be slot one
okay
so that should work
i didn't do a damn thing
okay why not
remove the rule delayed from tree
element shape function
and make it a rule
yep
okay
did something
doesn't seem like it did the right thing
[Music]
um might have to specify a style for the
frame to show up
what kind of a style
like do tree elements style
goes to
pink
all goes to pink
what the hell is going on here why are
there two sets of labels
so
right the
if you use a non-standard uh
like if you use something other than
just tell me how to get rid of those
other labels tree element
label goes to all goes to none
okay how do i get those frames to be
sensible
i guess inside the framed specified
background arrow white or something
i could come up back under the green
thing
okay
we can clearly make this look better
this has too much space right this looks
a lot better
am i making
sense yeah i can change the frame
margins for that okay so so i mean first
thing is okay let's try to get a spec
from design but i think you should
change the first step is just change the
frame margins it's not useful to have
the frame margins be that big by default
anyway
makes sense
um
but now that doesn't talk about the
splaying angles
right
we didn't we didn't have a reason to
talk about those
what
what
wait a minute did you make a change to
this
no
oh i know what happened i see what
happened
this was the this was the other version
of uh from desktop picking that up
okay all right so i think i agree with
the the aspect ratio thing but i think
we need to tighten up
this and i'm not certain i don't
understand why these borders are black
just seems wrong to me
could we consult design on that please
so we updated that
for 13.1 this is the spec that we got
okay fine but i think we missed the
frame margin spec but i would i would
like to re re-examine whether we want
black as the border color
okay
okay
okay
[Music]
there's is somebody from design here
yeah hi it's billy
okay well what do you think i mean do we
i think it at when it's i don't i just
don't see any reason to have the frame
margins be that big ever
yeah we can go we can go down and try
some new
some new titles
yeah
but but what do you think about the
border color
it's
i think i still see it as green in my
mind but we could lighten it up a little
bit if you're if it's registering so
dark for you uh yeah why don't we
lighten a little bit
the concern was that um
before we made that change the border
was way too light so
fine
too ghostly
if we didn't have anything in the
element
right but you see i think we've now gone
to unlabel the direction
right to the unlabeled tree being the
main case where you don't have anything
in the element
am i making sense i mean what happens if
i remove the label from one of these
elements here
what does it go to does it go to one of
these or does it go to what does it go
to
no so the round nodes become small
circles and the square nodes become
small squares
okay well so those need to be treated
perhaps especially
in the case where there's nothing in it
to not go too ghostly but that doesn't
mean when there is something in it that
needs to have
you know that it should have a um
such a dark border
make sense
if you can billy if you could try
mocking something during this meeting
that would be very helpful
and you can use this code here if you
know that background color you can stick
the background color in here you can
stick the color you know the colors in
here you can say frame margin you know
frame style arrow blah
et cetera right
yes let me take a screenshot
well i would use code i mean here i'll
use code
okay okay because then we can actually
play with it properly i sent you it in
chat
okay all right let's move on the lighted
trees design
oh
yeah that's also um
okay so is this a real thing now
no this isn't implemented yet so
currently if you have more than 10 nodes
or more than 10 children at a node then
all the remaining ones get combined into
a single node with that skeleton
with the number of delighted nodes
and you asked for that to be
modernized yeah yeah it needs to be
i don't think it should be an appearance
of a node i think it should be some
other appearance
but i don't know which of these
appearances is right
comments from people
yeah i like the ones that don't have an
actual frame there yeah i think that's
what we need it's like
really one node it's kind of strange
i'm sorry
like the way we're currently doing it
it's like one node that's really
standing for multiple nodes which is
kind of strange
yeah
well the only thing is that this is
going to look
disconnected here i mean
you know what i kind of favor
is that this
i was thinking you know this thing would
somehow be become dotted
the actual edge would somehow become
dotted maybe that's stupid
christopher do you have some ideas here
i don't have any strong opinion i think
a lot of these look good
what if it was framed but the background
was white
better
yeah i mean really the only thing would
just be that i think it should be
unambiguous that it's a skeleton and not
just another node that has maybe some
weird characters in it yeah avery is
suggesting
uh six with the illusion on top
i think that's not unreasonable i think
the dot is nice
um
now
you know
eventually we're going to have a new
what happens in a too big
thing here
ah
too short of that
no you see we see we see this
maybe that's what we want to use here
even perhaps something like that grey
lozenge
that makes sense to people
yep
except that it doesn't need the um
it doesn't need the thing on the on the
right hand side it doesn't need the the
secondary. right it just needs the
i'm just going to look stupid
it was just one dot dot dot
so i'm saying
right because it's at the end
yeah
i do like the idea of having something
with some gravitas to it to indicate
things are being alighted because i
worry about things being alighted
um
you know invisibly alighted
see what i'm saying
yep um
okay if we were going to do a lozenge
with a dot dot how would it work it
would be dot dot
[Music]
for some reason the dot dot dot on the
right hand side makes more sense to me
than on the left hand side yeah
look there's a possibility of a lozenge
here
with the dot dots in it with a number on
top of the dot dot dots
can we try that billy could you mark
that up
um
uh yeah sure which one
i was kind of looking at the uh trying
to figure out the um
font color isn't working so i was having
some issues with the uh tree
thing for some reason what is it what
what font color isn't looking that's i'm
sure a user issue on my end uh
and not with the uh font color itself
then you can um
[Music]
chat with the end about that okay okay
okay so here
what we're proposing is taking this kind
of lozenge
putting it here
with a dot dot
and a little number on top
okay
okay
now we need to check what that looks
like if it's six thousand nodes or
something and the number overwhelms the
dot dot dot
am i making sense
[Music]
maybe it is better to have the lozenge
with the the number and then dot dot
after it
is that clear what that would mean if
you saw that
yes
all right well let's try mocking that
billy and um
and then ian try putting it in
okay
okay
it should look and should it sorry
should it look like how it does right
there in the uh well i'm suggesting okay
cool the gray background and you know
white i mean obviously the fonts have to
match and so on and so well no the fonts
actually don't have to match the fonts
could be just like this
because that font doesn't match the
font that's a meta font so to speak
there
indicating you know meta information
rather than the actual raw tape data
here
so it's not exactly comparable but if
you look for example at information of
plot there's illusion with ellipses and
a total
for options
and it has the
ellipses on the left hand side
so if we look under options this is
chevron to open it and then on the right
hand side after those
when it's closed it says there's 64
total
not exactly the same scenario but
doing something kind of similar yeah
that's something we've done
kinda nice
let's try that as well as the the
lozenge with the thing on the other side
okay let's try something where there's a
lozenge like this
i do think that the total is more useful
than the number of lighted most of the
time
you see what i'm saying guys
yeah that makes sense
so then there'll be something with a
styled
version of this maybe it's in a white
lozenge maybe i don't know what it is
but something which looks pretty much
like this
okay
all right ready to move on
maximal minimal
so these were things that were proposed
um and then we had wfr versions put in
we're circling back to them because
minimal buy and maximal buy
are one of or two of only three
functions that have we have a buy
version for but not a non-buy version
for the other being group buy
and basically
looking whether these are
sufficiently important to have
built-in functions for
minimal and men
uh numerical ordering versus
canonical ordering
i think that's incredibly obscure
i mean i think
the alternative would be an option to
men
the men is bear arms right yeah i know
that but it would be like union
so what's a what's a use case where the
numerical ordering will be different
from the canonical ordering and you
actually want the canonical one
for for the min for instance
i mean i don't really understand where
men
okay so look
if i say min
[Music]
of
abc
it's just going to do that now if i say
minimal
of abc i have a feeling it's just going
to give a
yeah
i see
it's not completely useless
yeah except that it's it seems very hard
to understand
yeah and
good go ahead yeah i was gonna say it's
it's sometimes useful to
illustrate the
the ways in which
canonical ordering differs from
numerical ordering um you know the
classic example is when we do something
like sort and minus infinities at the
end because
well there's no question of canonical i
mean this is the thing where this will
be first of sort of that yeah it's first
of all
i i know and but i mean you know that's
the thing that i thought i do fairly
routinely is say first of sort to get a
sample of you know a canonical sample of
some gathered thing for example or is it
first of numerical sort
well i never used that no i it usually
isn't in my case
i've usually got um
i'm saying that but this proposed
function
nick was saying an important thing is
that it's numerical and not canonical
the is cannot numerical right right so
this would be first of numerical sort
yeah but it also does a different thing
because it it has
this here
is returning a whereas this here is
returning unevaluated
right i understand that yeah yeah
i think it's confusing and i i would say
i'm not a fan
okay anybody else any other comments
we can look at it
again some other time but i'm not a fan
okay
yeah i mean it does exist in the
wolverine function repo it's somewhat
popular but not
well how popular let's see how popular
it is let's wait let's wait six months
see how popular it is okay
okay
an operative form of fixed point
seems kind of like
something of a no-brainer
yeah i mean it it made sense to me and
nick's here also who proposed it but i
don't know
i can't think of any reason why we
wouldn't do it
okay so
syntactic
conflict that i'm aware of
now could we do the same thing for nest
[Music]
it would have to be that that's a bit
weird
[Music]
i'm more of a believer in this this
seems useful
okay yeah we can do that that's pretty
straightforward
all right are we really on to wfrs here
because because are you really there's
nothing else that's come up uh there are
other things but there's a lot of people
who aren't available at the moment so
we're trying to get through some
backlogged
items okay fine fine
um comment
uh something i want to talk about and i
don't know what meeting to put it in
um i have a plot
and
i have stuff that is so let's say i do
this i say list plot
of append
range of 10
comma a thousand
okay all right
you don't see the thousand
right i want an indication that there's
something there
[Music]
an outlier indicator or something yeah i
want some kind of thing that's a little
you know pointy thing up here that
indicates that there's something missing
now you really just want something that
shows that the plot range is is not you
know it's true
yeah yeah but i'd be happy to see that
there's a you know
a thing that goes off to infinity in a
few places
um
where there's just a little nick here at
the top or a little arrow type thing
like like a little karate type thing
here it just indicates there's something
off off off screen there it wouldn't be
on the axis it would be
no i would say it would be up there
that's the obvious place to put it
you mean in the corner yeah i mean well
in this particular case because it's the
last element but i mean
if i if i say well you have to imagine
in
is that what you're saying
yes that's what i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying here
so
you should you should imagine the case
of an orbit like a random scatter plot
where the plot range is just kind of in
the middle of it there's random stuff in
every direction
yeah well what should it do
i'm saying
okay
so i'm saying if the value
is x y
where x is on screen and y is not
y is bigger than screen so to speak it
should have a sort of on the x on the
level of
on on x here it should have a little
nick up here
similarly in a scatter plot
if it is on screen at the in in terms of
y
it should have a nick over here
and if it's off screen diagonally you
know so it's neither in the x range or
the y range there's no indication or
it's in there no no no i think there's a
nick in the corner
so i'm just worried about if you have a
scatter plot you know if you just did a
scatter plot a bunch of random points in
a disk let's say and then you just set
the plot range to be only you know 0.1
or something in the disk is radius one
then you're going to have nicks all
around the frame because there's little
points everywhere no i think it depends
on how how
i don't think that's going to look that
stupid
but also there is a comment i mean
nothing else obviously there have to be
a way of disabling it because it is a
common use case that you have a big data
set you want to watch oh
i agree i agree i agree it's not obvious
this should be there by default
although what it could be
is it could not be there by default but
it should be could be some mouse you
know some hover effect by default
could only be on by default when plot
range is automatic
but if you set a plot range yeah that's
a good point if plot range is automatic
you do want it on by default that's
correct
that's that's what you would want yes
maybe maybe one other point would be um
i mean
you could imagine having similar things
with line plots well
i know there are conventions that people
have for you know like you know you have
little dashes at the end or something if
the line plot's going off the scale
yes
uh right right well i agree anyway this
is maybe we can cut this fragment of the
discussion give it to brett when he
returns we can discuss this
avery does that make sense
okay
so this is maybe a jumping off point for
a larger discussion but this is safe
take is basically take with an implicit
up to
but it also works with a effectively a
down to specification which up to
doesn't support you know i was wanting
this recently so when i
okay let me give you a use case
okay so let's say i say
uh string take
of word list the english language comma
minus two
okay
okay it's going to fail it's going to
give a bunch of messages right
because there are words of length lesson
two yep
okay
i wanted this i was trying to do you
know up two minus two
by which i meant
really down to i mean
in a sense up to
taking up to the minus tooth element
whereby up to i mean
the span from nothing to
you know the minus tooth element minus
second element
right
why do we not have that work
i mean is that is there a different
piece of functionality for down to
that's different from
that i don't think there is i think it's
does that element exist
i mean i think it's a little weird that
it says up to -2 but i have to say when
i was doing this
that would have been the natural thing
for me to put in there
right i don't yeah i i was wondering you
know does having a separate
wrapper called down two makes sense and
i think it's just gonna be annoying
super confusing yeah up to my negative
number is maybe a little
counter-intuitive but it's also the
natural thing to do and i imagine the
plumbing ought be the same what about up
to a span spec you know like with a step
size
that's
ugly
but you want the same behavior somehow
okay so wait a minute so what you're
saying is
basically what it's saying is
you know if if it can be achieved
achieve it
otherwise don't
yes give me give me all the elements
that fit this spec and
don't give me anything if
if it's not big enough
yeah right i mean it's a misnomer when
we call it up to but it's a very useful
behavior
i agree
i mean so this normally okay let's just
see what this does
i think string take is uh you know that
index you know start begin end in a list
or start and step in a list this worked
fine oh did it okay yeah
just hear it do it safely so to speak
look i think of the possible names that
we could use for this concept up to
is not that obscure because the cases
the simple cases are very easy to
understand
right and wrapping it up to around this
you know we could say up to the
up to this collection of elements
a subset of this collection of elements
we could think of it as as um
you know up to this yeah i i like this
idea i would i support
allowing up to for all
uh
take specifications
i mean i think the really interesting
one is the part specification case
where we don't have that at all where if
you say something like you know abc
and then we said up to
five
five yeah what
return three s
c here
[Music]
oh i thought it would return nothing
yeah my initial thought was nothing but
well you might be right but up two
represents uh
i mean up to represents us
if you just do wait
that's a span usually
well
okay yeah i guess it represents a span i
i'm just going to do this because it
only appears in take and take you can
normally just give it an integer but i
guess you can also give it a span so
but it also works in partition doesn't
it
up to right and that's the place where
you participate an integer that's the
best place that updo was ever
yeah that's what made partition useful
for me
you say up to three
yeah it's lovely
but you can't have a span there so in
that context the up two is is like an
integer
yes
but in the case of take and maybe there
are other functions where it also allows
a span
well the take is kind of ambiguous i
mean if you give it i'm talking about it
up to given an integer argument right
because if you give it a span argument
it's a different story but if you give
an integer argument in the case of take
it's ambiguous whether it's representing
a span or an integer because they do the
same thing
good point
yes the question is for part if we did
support it for part should it be an
integer or spam
it should be an integer because that's
the useful case
the useful case is get me the
right and if you want to span you can
put a span into you're up to
or you can put a span outside if you're
up to or something like that
yeah i hadn't thought about a span with
up to for individual elements
well i also i mean the other possibility
which is getting kind of funky isn't up
to with a second argument that is what
to do if it's out of range
[Music]
yeah default value yeah i mean i don't
think that's totally crazy at all
because like look up etc
right i mean the issue would be um
ah
nick you were saying you have something
to add here
i was just reminding that i have a
function with the different semantics
up to in spanish
so
it's basically spun treats all
as a
indication that is once maximum number
of elements if all it within a span in
some ways right if it's the first
element you take maximum number
like
supporting any other limits and up to
infinity should be the same as all
okay hold on hold on all this logic you
can have to
treat it as
the same as up to infinity is the same
as all
yes
so the integer inside up to
should be a number of elements
so that any other specification in this
span
it kind of holds
okay hold on hold on hold on
what what are you what is the bottom
line of what you're saying i mean oh
it's are you disputing that up two of a
span makes sense
or are you saying that there's a case
for up to infinity being equivalent to
all
it's kind of it's a little bit tricky i
don't know what i'm disputing it just
it's a little bit confusing but up to
all up to infinity and all means within
a span
because if you usually use span if the
communication says that when you use all
their within a span it tries to
extract the maximum number of elements
okay let's take a look if we say take
of this
oh my gosh
um take this comma
yeah that does what i would expect
and now
are you saying that this
well that isn't going to work
but you're saying that this
or up to wrapped around the whole thing
should work and be equivalent to
all there
and maybe it already works it's just not
consistent
with all our
elements
it does work
it doesn't work
i'm not against it
i don't describe that it doesn't work
it's just
up to in different elements it's like in
different places of a span is not really
consistent it's like when they have up
to in the second element what they are
actually wanna extract
is two elements
maximum two elements that is consistent
with other specifications in the span so
like starting from minus one with step
minus one
just two elements
i'm confused i mean basically okay
let's let's break this off for a second
i mean the so basic point is we want to
extend up to
but there is a question of what the
precise calculus of up to actually is so
for example and up to outside of a span
versus an up to as in an element of a
span how do those compare
is that and i don't understand i mean in
in the case of span range
what is it doing here it's converting
specifications
it basically converts span
with up to
and o into just a range
so it's prone to oh i see i see i got i
finally understood what this is
um
okay
uh
you see an example it just opened the
scope under all cases listed there
with up to in different elements in
different position of a span and what is
it
what does it mean
okay
this this requires more investigation
than so can we break this off
nick can we i mean this seems like a
good idea let's basically plan to
implement up to in the negative things
but we need to understand these corner
cases
yeah and talk to danny about it when he
gets back and then okay and i and i
would like to have the possibility of an
up to
with a default value but that may be
crazy
okay where the default default value is
nothing
in other words omit the element
[Music]
but there could be a non-default value
but that might be crazy
okay
yeah okay i also would like to point out
i don't know what up two does in
multi-dimensional
but i guess take has has each each um
uh dimension is a separate argument of
take
right
all right
next item
string contains all
so this is basically all true of string
contains q
it's another one that is reasonably
popular
the question is whether it is
sufficiently interesting to be a
standalone function versus just
all true applied to string contains q
i think this is not totally
uninteresting i mean wouldn't it be
string contains
all q
and i understand why
okay i'm confused here
the reason that this is not working with
string contains q is that string
contains q if there's a list there
treats them as alternatives is that
correct
correct it does treat it as alternatives
which is slightly questionable
etai and i are working on improving the
documentation for that
gives a list of results for each of the
strings threads
does it thread well so it says gives a
list of results right i know it says
that but for a list of strings in the
first argument threads for a list of
patterns in the second argument it
treats the list as alternatives of those
patents oh yeah this is threatening the
first okay
so does it commit to the fact that it
treats them as alternatives
all of the functions in this family do
that
so string match q string free q
i see which makes sense for string match
q
to do that
but for string contains q
i mean i think there's an argument that
string string contains all q
is not a crazy function to have
i would like to provisionally suggest we
have it
okay
i mean unless there is a pattern matcher
rapper that we can imagine having
the headdress for the pattern that says
yeah i think it's stupid i think it's
stupid i think that's stupid
that's really confusing
yeah
i would agree it's going to be hard to
propagate even if we like it but
yeah i think
having the the function with an explicit
name like that makes a lot of sense
okay string contains all q
headq
so this is another popular predicate um
it's basically
a predicate version of match queue
yeah
it's just underscore list or
alternatives underscore integer for that
second case if that's what you're
talking about yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying right i mean but but the thing is
you do see code very often i do this
myself quite often
of saying
if head of blah yeah if head of blah
equals string then do this
[Music]
i'm not wild about the name head cue
right it sounds like it's asking if this
is the head
right or
i feel like this is literally a single
character away from what match queue
already does
well in other words you're saying if i
said
match queue
underscore list
yeah that's identical to head queue of
list
yeah except i never do this
i mean i should
should be
that's not a great argument
there's a difference if your head is a
complex expression you can't use this
underscore
right
well can't you say blank of and then a
complex abstraction yeah you can
then you can yeah but or you could say
match queue of whatever you want compose
with head
and that's also the same thing
yeah but
for some reason i feel like this is the
kind of thing that's that's that's
really easy to do right now
except for somebody's super common
operation
well the head of blah blah blah if head
of blah blah is not equal to list
do whatever
that's really common
if you're doing that in the context of
error handling then
that's
that's that's not the best well
okay well so what should we do i mean if
head equals
if head of list equals list blah blah
blah otherwise do something different
that's the common case that i've used it
well there's just list q
in that particular case there is
i just think that it can be very
confusing when we have sort of a
function that's like so so
you know similar to an existing thing
yeah i kind of agree
okay that raises another question that i
had asked on an email um which was about
for loops
okay
i want to know why do people use them
what can you do
with a four
what's easy to do with a four that's not
easy to do with any construct we
currently have
is it an incremental return thing
do you see what i'm saying
whatever you do here
i mean
what do you usually want to return from
a for loop
i mean
why do you not use a do to do a for loop
or is it just laziness and weirdness
i mean i think there's different
paradigms that people are used to
yeah okay but that's another part of it
i want to know it's not an argument for
it but it's i want to know whether
here's a case where where i mean i
wouldn't use four for this but here's a
case where where do i think makes it
more difficult is suppose you have
a list that you're iterating over but as
you're iterating over it you might
append to that list
i see what you're saying
so that's something where usually you
know i would probably use like a while
loop for that yeah okay
so in other words the
the test
is on a structure that is being modified
right yeah i mean the most common case
is just you're iterating over a
structure that's being modified but yeah
and fundamentally that's kind of a
dangerous operation because you know
well first of all
i mean you probably have to make an
assumption that it's only being modified
in certain ways you know for example
it's only being appended to
um if we're prepended to that would you
know complicate things so what will be
it what would be a functional
programming way of doing this iterating
over a structure that's being modified
so what you would have is you would have
a modification function
what do you mean by iterating over it
i mean i think that's that's the
probably the functional programming way
to do it is to i mean basically anything
you can use wild for like this you can
use nesquile for um
yeah
okay
i still want to talk about this small
and we have a few more people here this
but this is a good point i think that
can we bring this back the discussion of
four and versus nest while versus this
point about iterating other structures
that are being modified
let's see muhammad in live stream asked
what happened to the function head map
what did happen to headmap
reading or something
no for chronology um the
uh
um
no head map
is the thing that goes into
let's see map with heads goes to true
maps
into the head of an expression
but there's no
nothing that maps into the head but not
into the other elements the expression
what about map at
map at zero
you're saying map at
yeah
of f onto g of x of y
well that does seem to do it doesn't it
and how would i do it if i wanted to go
if i wanted to map all
onto the head
so let's say i have
this
is any way of doing that
extended to support patterns and you
could do triple blink
yeah you'd have to do them each one you
could do
zero and then a list one comma zero and
then another list
well you could also map at one comma one
comma zero
i need to end in zero not begin with
zero
okay you're suggesting that i could do a
map or here
yeah
which probably has an operator
why doesn't it have an operating form
why doesn't have a freaking operator
form
i mean map certainly has an operator
form
uh
why doesn't matt paul have an operative
form just seems crazy maybe it just felt
busy cracks
yeah i mean it only has one usage so
i think it should have an operative form
i think that's just a mistake yeah i
think it's just a pretty obscure
function
yeah
uh been updated since version one
according to the docs
it was not as useful as one had hoped it
would be
i mean it it
yeah
and in a
wow
it's
it's old um okay you can use operator
applied map all of that for something
right but i think map all should have an
object form so that's a definite thing
now avery is commenting that we have a
version of head map
sw notes
under miscellaneous
what is this
what the heck is this
anybody understand what this is
oh i see
oh okay so this is a very different much
more useful thing
right
okay so let's just take a look at what
this is
okay so it's now got an open form as
well
oops
what is that
what the heck is that doing
why does it say that
could you clear all head map
oh yeah i think it's because it's trying
to evaluate
so evaluate the first
the operator form before the other one
no because we didn't define the operator
form yet
oh no because the second one it takes x
triple under why does it take x triple
underscore
it's trying
it's evaluating
the first part of the head map here yeah
the head map there because it's x triple
underscore above so it's trying to
operate before the operator form exists
so if i switch these definitions it
should work you climb theoretically
yeah is it is it a good idea i'm not
sure is it a good idea to to make it
various like that
with the triple blank there
seems questionable to me but let's take
a look yeah let's try it
um
i said
try it with the bear arms
i don't know the operative form seems
like it might as well be their hogs
well actually
right presumably actually if you just
make the x double underscore
then it will it'll all work because
otherwise the the
triple underscore oh yes yes
right yes that's right because the
i mean in fact what the hell would
triple underscore do
well it would return f open close g open
close et cetera
which also wouldn't be useless no it's
not useless i i think there's an
argument the triple underscore is right
right but
but but then the operator form can't
work and the operator form is pretty
useful
why can't it work
oh
underscore yeah yeah yeah right yeah
it'll never be used yes i see it um
right so really that has to be the right
form right so that's an argument maybe
for putting that in a list because if
you put it in a list then you could give
an empty list it'll be equivalent to
that
triple underscore thing
no but i think that it's useful to be
able to do the case
this case is useful
right i mean the question is whether you
have to give x y in a list or whether
you give well oh sorry no you're right
it's ambiguous otherwise yeah fine fine
is the name head map
anything other than utterly obscure
map through and through map were also
suggested
i usually use through as an example of a
totally
useless function name yeah yeah i know
true was a mistake i mean through was a
function that that
i thought was going to be widely used
i can't remember i never remember what
through does i mean through
basically
basically through with a different
syntax yeah it's the syntax of through
is what makes it confusing well but it's
also it's it's it's less general in a
useful way
like through is to throw us to heads as
thread is to lists somehow
right in practice the main usage of i
mean there are all sorts of things that
you're supposed to be able to use
through for like if you have you know f
plus g
of x yeah return f of x plus g of x i've
never used that the only thing i ever
used through for is in the middle of
long composition chains you can use it
to sort of add a fork
um
so you do through compose
list fg you know compose whatever you
want and that can be sort of in the
middle of your
composition and it and it does nice
stuff is this a useful thing i mean the
name is ridiculous but through
[Laughter]
i mean
there's effectively an operator form up
through yeah an operator that's in kind
of talking in the states we pronounce it
throughout
um
i mean this this is the same as the
operator form of head map that we're
talking about isn't it
yeah yeah
i think that's fairly useful
yeah except the name of the roof
absolutely yeah
yeah i mean head map is just really
obscure
but if we concentrate on this form
what will we call this
headlist no
so i assume by the way you can't give it
anything other than a list of function
names like in through you can give it
you know f plus g we're not bringing
that over to head map
well that's not obvious lists
i think it's just lists because i think
anything other than this
actually it'll probably work oh i'm
thinking try giving it f plus g it might
actually just work because map works on
on f plus g doesn't it
yeah yeah yeah well that's lovely but
but this
is going to do something utterly stupid
indeed which is why which is why that
you know that this is why through i mean
right this is why this is the problem
with through is that through kind of
assumes that you can i mean it's the
same as the problem with thread is that
you build this intermediate expression
and you sort of pray that it doesn't
blow up at you
but there's not necessarily a reason to
believe that
right well that's why threat is not
useful on things other than you know
things
yeah right so another use case this is
one that's impossible with through is if
you give it an association of functions
oh that's interesting right so you
should just work with head map with this
definition which would be very nice but
with through you can't do it because you
have to have the association open
bracket x but that evaluates
that is nice
that's definitely nice
yeah go ahead well the main problem of
through is that you can't really make
its head unrelated
it's like i had a
few cases when i just wanted to use it
but it's i couldn't just not evaluate
this list of
functions because i don't want to use a
list ahead i want to use something else
and it's evolutes
and i can just block it
you mean like this plus case where you
have the two f of x or something yeah
and head map would help with that i just
wrap it when i radiate it and you have
to annulate it map it also in the
definition in order for it to work
in this definition up here but you're
saying that that if that definition was
done correctly
then this would just work
yeah
this is a useful function all right what
should it be called
map through
i don't think there's any mapping in it
it's more like it's definitely mapping
there's just no through all right
there's definitely mapping
there's both mapping and throughing but
but but map is a name that succeeded and
threw is a name that that failed so
yeah but i don't think that um
okay so this is so we talked about some
of these things here
all applied
so i think i i was actually talking i
think to conor the other day about this
and uh and the the fake name we gave it
was map head
why are you talking about map though
there's no mapping going on here i mean
it's mapping over
this is mapping it's just that it's
mapping into functions instead of
mapping in the arguments yeah i mean
a crazy this is not the way to do it but
um
well actually
no right actually sorry this is the way
it's working right i mean it's literally
the same as math it's just that you put
the list
you know the first starting instead of
the second argument
i'm sorry yes i mean that's what this is
doing yes
what what are you saying what
the
i mean yes this is the analog of
so it's definitely mapping i don't know
why you're saying you don't think it's
map
because i wasn't thinking of this map i
was thinking of it as as um
it just seems very obscure that it's
mapping head map take a level spec
like
it insert x
at all of the sub
of the first argument according to a
level spec
maybe but
but
well i think i think you could do that
but then it would it would get rid of
this double underscore behavior we have
right now is there a way for it to be
multiple arguments
going into the functions
into the heads
well we do right now that's why if you
do a head map of
f x y
okay to do it without the sub value
though so it's clear what's going on
because a right the operator form is not
yeah
but in the operator form with it okay
it's var in the non-operator form yeah
right okay
it's always a little scary
okay but the name here so the question
is what the name is
um
sandra is saying it should be apply all
no because it's not an apply
well
also all all sounds like
map all or replace all
which means at all levels
that's true
at best it would be something like apply
list
it's like a place list or something
well it will be construct list
that's obscure but that's that's use
another to use another function that
that hasn't really caught on yes
well construct
it is in fact construct list
well except you say it doesn't have to
be a list
um
no i don't know construct map
that's not
that's no good either
um
put something in chat
hopefully yeah
right the level spec is a coherent thing
it's just a question of um
you know if we have to pick between that
and the vera args behavior
right yeah
because because i think if we want to be
able to support multiple arguments to
the function
well
right one point
is you can just map apply over your
this is a weird thing to to do but like
you can map apply over your
your list of functions
and then you can give it a list in the x
and that'll do the same thing look what
about the possibility of the verags the
operator form
inserts a list
that crazy that the operator form
is equivalent to
first argument list of things that were
in the operating in the in the curried
piece
but first of all i think the operator
form shouldn't have different
shouldn't you know the operator form
should just be a different syntax for
the non-operator form well i know but
i'm suggesting well okay but i'm
suggesting radically different stuff no
i understand but i'm suggesting that the
operator form could package its varag's
curried second piece
into a list
for use in the non-operator form
i don't know if we ever do that i mean
so what i'm suggesting is
that you know
head map of f
i think that's kind of crazy because in
the single argument case you really
don't want it to do that
um and it's sort of weird if it has
different single versus multi-argument
behavior that makes sense
don't forget you have to give a list of
f g or something
oh yeah
wait a minute nick is saying
we need a name for
what is this thing
well this is basically a thing in the
map argument in the
in the definition
so you can apply it to x and that and
then to the function
which construct with the arguments the
other way around
yeah
so it's a hash applied to a first
argument
when
when exactly is just applied to x and to
f
right it's going to turn f of x right
apparent
it's like not not two arguments but
carried current from
right yes
so if you had a name for this we could
just use it that would be
this this new name of x would be an
argument to map and this this new
function that we're trying to name would
be this name with them up
can't you just do it with apply though
right like if you had head map like try
try this with the existing definition of
head map just run head map of apply
slash at
you know f and g
and then in the second argument give it
a list x y and that's your turn f of x y
and g of x y yeah
so that mimics the behavior we have
right now of the head map fg and then
the sequence x y
so this is so that we can avoid the var
args and have a level spec
yeah
i mean this is if we didn't have the
varax this is how you get the same
behavior which isn't that bad right and
and head map could then have options at
some point if we wanted to
right like head zero true whatever that
means right right
actually i guess that does have a pretty
clear meaning it's just kind of very
unclear when you'd ever want it
well okay but so
you're suggesting
right yeah you could clearly you can do
this
um
but the question is what is this
function i mean this is some kind of
outer product construct or something or
not out of products some what the heck
is it
it's like it's like map but instead of
wrapping something around
sub-expressions you're wrapping the
sub-expressions around something
danny over here he'd suggest pam instead
yes
um
i need to run off here in a second but
but uh
okay we need this function we just need
a name
head map is just too freaking obscure
okay it takes
a list of functions
i mean i kind of feel like there's a
something applied
that makes it sound like some operator
form thing
but it is an opera i mean if it is an
operator form if the primary
form but it's not it's not i don't think
that's the primary case i think it's
useful without that
i think it's much more useful in an
operative form and some kind of chain of
things
but but normally we name functions we
name them based on their non-operator
forms and they happen to have operator
forms well yes i mean we could document
the operator form first
i just think i i've used this case of
the non-operator form many times like
it's a useful thing in that case as well
yeah fair enough
um
i'm not sure i think i have to go but uh
uh
okay to be continued next time we should
start on this one
and see if we can come up with a good
idea for a name yep we'll maybe send any
suggestions to t ild and
fine we'll talk about it again next time
sounds good all right thanks much and uh
thanks to folks on our live